[Music]
you need to be an early bird to have
Venice to yourself these days this is
when Piazza San Marco is at its most
stunning but it doesn't take long for
that to change mass tourism has been a
growing problem here for years
day-trippers and cruise passengers
descending on this island city with good
intentions but are they driving this
place to its extinction and what can we
all learn about Venice's struggles
[Music]
this is what happened here earlier in
the month it was a miracle no one died
the few who were injured are now
recovering
[Music]
river taxi skipper Marco saw the crash
just a few hundred meters from the jetty
that's in mark's square did you expect
this sort of thing might happen such big
ships in this small place yes yes fish
we should be changing the change Aria
you should to go they the cruise ship
suitable in another place of air of
lagoon locals aren't remotely surprised
about what happened here but there is a
hope that it will put a real focus on
this city whose problems may be linked
to mass tourism but they go well well
beyond that the number of tourists here
these days far outweighs the number who
actually live here back on Easter Sunday
a hundred thousand people visited in
just one day this is a story of chronic
mismanagement a crumbling city failed
engineering projects and huge
environmental challenges we're out on
the canal with 22 year old student and
Venetian vittorio de most oh he's taking
us on the alternative tour of this city
so here on this side you'll see the
erosion and as you can see there's the
green line that is where the water
usually arrives and then beneath that
you see there it's all slowly coming to
pieces
big hanawon this is delivering something
that's part of the problem there are
just too many people too many boats yeah
absolutely
we head out into the lagoon on which
Venice sits unto an engineering project
that's become a tragic joke for locals
on the various port mouths of Venice and
what it's supposed to do is to come up
when you have an extreme high tide
that's usually over 130 meters and was
supposed to do is decrease the amount of
water that's coming into Venice
so to decrease the amount of the high
tide from what they said it was supposed
to be finished in 2011 but right now
they've postponed the day to 2022
throughout it's been plagued with
allegations of corruption and
mismanagement environmentalists claim
its design is flawed anyway masses are a
vital part of the ecosystem of the
lagoon and they're being destroyed and
slowly with a drenching of the canals
and the hiring of the of the water level
these are slowly getting lost you're
starting to lose even the ecosystem is
it starting to be imbalanced so the
ecosystem effectively breaks down as a
result of mass tourism and the desire of
everyone to come and see Venice yes in a
strange way the more people come to
Venice the harder it is for the
ecosystem to survive we head back past a
sand Bank which Vittorio and his friends
cleared a few weeks ago and another that
still needs to be done very high tides
and rising sea levels are a real
challenge here now the city floods
regularly far more than it used to and
the erosion is devastating lays all this
light that measures how high tide is
concerned locals feel the authorities
are not taking the challenges seriously
enough they funded and installed their
own tide gauge one of the names on the
plaque is Vittorio's mothers and it's
her he says we should talk to
[Music]
jane de Mostow is from london originally
but a venetian for 25 years and an
environmental scientist who now
depressingly finds her subject all
around her Venice is a unique city but
this the single critical issues that are
challenging Venice are very common to
other places but it's true we have the
benefit here in Venice of seeing things
kind of close-up and magnified and also
having an impact from the scale of this
city because it's relatively small and
tightly packed and I do think Venice is
kind of the canary in the mine because
it has so much international attention
on what happens to Venice everybody
thinks of Venice most people love Venice
so we really are at the coalface like
you say of observing that the future is
possible for years Venice has been seen
as perfectly representative of Italy's
problems with corruption and
dysfunctional government but it's become
clear that it reflects much much more
than that encapsulated in one la goon
city are many of the challenges that
we're all facing in the distance
thousands more tourists prepare to
arrive the debate over whether to allow
these ships here has yo-yoed for years
in 2014 the port of Venice proposed a
ban then regional government overturned
it then the central government
overturned that saying that by 2015 they
would all be banned and so it went on
but they are still here
on the corner of the square is gelateria
alta daro
opened in 1948 by Giovanni Bob aleck
bringing ice cream to the city for the
first time it's run by his
great-grandson now but for how much
longer I'm here because I want to
to do something for this city I try and
I think that a lot of person not only
Venetians but everybody in the world who
loved Venice and want to do it in my
opinion we have to pick about a city
against the pollution against the hover
to Lisbon so we have to decide how many
person every day and and so on maybe we
will do something good for Venice so do
you worry about about your city quite a
bit yes yes recently more than I used to
you're young you were telling me you're
you and your friends that you've noticed
the young people are more active more
worried yes yes absolutely it's gotta be
a good thing absolutely we're trying to
fix things in the city that's been here
for a thousand years and I don't want to
be part of the population that lets it
all just slip away